[Musique]
montargis 15000 habitants ici entre le
30 mai et le 1er juin 2016
eh bien le niveau du loing est passé de
50 cm à 3 mètres de haut alors un an
après où en est on quels souvenirs
reviennent à l'esprit que faut-il
changer
eh bien les commerçants du centre ville
prenne la parole
et ça s'appelle c'est vous qui ce but
[Musique]
on a une tablette et quelques questions
on peut vous les posez on a installé un
petit peu plus loin je suis merci venez
avec nous
[Musique]
alors quelle image vous revient en
premier alors la première image chez
l'eau qui passe par dessus mes bottes en
allant chez mes parents et d'emprunter
cette rue que j'ai toujours connu
direction la maison de mon enfance par
laquelle en fait en deux heures de temps
on est passé d'un niveau normal à une
hauteur d'eau au genou voilà qui passe
dans les bottes ma rue c'était un fleuve
un fleuve qui se déversait dans un océan
parce qu'il ya une grande place devant
les sens et c'est vrai que c'est le
souvenir qu'on en garde assez facilement
un raz-de-marée de la boue qui a tout en
aimé jouer mes doudous mais construction
mais jeux de cartes et puis au niveau
des égouts dans dans la boulangerie
l'eau sortait et le niveau commence à
monter à monter vers 3 heures de l'après
midi on a commencé à avoir de l'eau
arrivait dans la rue d'à côté et là
c'était impressionnant en l'espace de
deux heures là toute la boulangerie tous
à l'eau monte et on voyait qu'on ne
pouvait pas l'arrêter rien du tout
qui a fallu une bonne semaine pour tout
remettre en ordre
il a fallu tout l'avait jeté toute la
viande qu'on avait tous les frigos tout
était plein comme c'était le mardi on
venait de recevoir les livraisons et où
plus de quatre mois pour tout remettre
entre moi et le liant pour tout remettre
en ordre c'est à dire pour hacher les
sols foire à celle et les murs faut
recommander le mobilier faut faire
vérifier toute l'électricité le
chauffage tout moi ça a été très rapide
parce que déjà l'établissement était
neuf et j'ai eu 40 50 cm d'eau donc en
cinq jours j'ai pu rouvrir
alors combien de temps pour tout
remettre en ordre
cinq mois il a fallu cinq mois de
fermeture pour pouvoir
pourquoi veut tout remettre en ordre
alors vous votre magasin n'a pas trop
souffert des inondations
non le magasin n'a pas souffert
physiquement des inondations après il ya
forcément
suspense économique donc aujourd'hui on
change encore un peu de matériel
mais sinon il ya aussi il faudrait faire
des travaux à l'intérieur parce que bon
les murs ils ont quand même but il ya
quand même même si c'est pas directement
du placo il ya du carrelage mais on voit
quand même que ça abus à l'intérieur ces
innovations en préouverture ben sahar
dynamiser l'activité
pour moi c'est extraordinaire et quand
vous écrivez justement j'ai du mal à
expliquer est-ce que les gens apprécient
ces nations ont dit on va se faire
plaisir on va sortir on va changer
l'esprit et puis on va passer du bon
temps et c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
commencé à sortir découvrir deux
endroits qu'ils avaient peut-être pas
encore découvert jusqu'ici mais je pense
que ça a dit jouer un petit peu
où en êtes vous concrètement aujourd'hui
on va plutôt bien
on va plutôt bien on a fait face
les inondations c'est c'est derrière
nous maintenant il faut regarder à
l'avant
[Musique]
qu'attendez-vous des politiques à ce
sujet au moins de nous dire clairement
ce qui s'est passé ça serait déjà bien
parce qu'on sait pas exactement si c'est
parce que c'était lui qui a été retenue
pour pas inonder plus loin et il dans
ces cas là c'est ça qui a peu provoqué
une brèche passé y avait trop de
résistance alors je dirais l'entretien
des berges déjà ce serait bien
l'entretien des berges et puis mettre en
place un système d' alerte
sur nos téléphones portables pour nous
dire attention il ya ce qui s'appelle
aujourd'hui arrête dérèglement
climatique
avec les conséquences on voit
qu'aujourd'hui il faut faire et que
logiquement beaucoup de choses et
aujourd'hui tous les pays sont pas prêts
à le faire tant ça s'est passé est un de
côté
[Musique]